no one cared about politics in brazil
until a few weeks ago
now everyone's an expert because in case
you missed it
[ __ ] you politics has reached the
southern hemisphere
jaya bolsonaro is the president-elect of
brazil
and the latest in a very interesting new
global trend
voters keep voting for the wrong thing
democracy just
doesn't work if voters don't vote for
who they're supposed to
but that's what keeps on happening and
the establishment
is getting annoyed let's take bolsonaro
i'm not saying he's far right but he's
certainly opinionated
if you could design a candidate that
people would do literally
anything not to vote for it would be
this guy
he is so unelectable it's like he's
taking the piss
he's unpleasant and bless him he doesn't
hide it either
in fact he's actually expressed himself
honestly
in public which never got anyone elected
in the good old days
former military man bolsonaro loves
torture hates gay people black people
doesn't like female people so much
either
he's a fanboy of brazil's old dictators
and yet he's still got
over 55 of brazilians to vote for him
including gay people
and female people which makes you wonder
just how bad was the other guy
bolsonaro has been labelled the trump of
the tropics by the
international media mainly because they
have no imagination and they don't like
either of them
trump was the wrong choice too a known
groper with a flexible relationship with
the truth
and he won generally speaking people
don't go to the polls thinking i want a
groper or a dictator to vote for
that's who i want in charge of my taxes
generally speaking
people are not racists or bigots either
so when they vote one in
the other options must be a total [ __ ]
show
brazil faces an epidemic of violence
and murder bolsonaro has offered to
shoot the criminals
pretty basic stuff but no one's offered
any better trump offered
change the democrats offered another
clinton
and then there's this lot
the liberal establishment you know the
good guys they really need something new
because amazingly calling pissed off
scared impoverished voters
stupid racists just isn't endearing them
i bet they keep trying it though i'm
sure it'll be fine